[MUSIC]
Hi class of 22, welcome to the GSB fam.
I'm Kerry and I'm recording this
from the very hot Houston, Texas.
>> Hey class of 22, welcome to the GSB,
my name is Emily, so
excited that you're here.
>> Hello class for 2022, I'm Robert
Siegel, a Lecturer at the Graduate School
of Business and
also a member of the MBA class from 1994.
We are so
excited to have him here with us.
You're about to go through a truly
transformational experience,
the likes of which none of us have
actually really gone through the way
you're going to go through it.
But we can't wait to see you in person,
we're so excited to have you here and
we want to welcome you to Stanford.
>> While we can't be together as we
normally would be in the classrooms or
in town square, we are still
an incredibly strong community.
>> We know that this is a fall
quarter unlike any other.
>> I'm not sure what the new normal will
be but one thing that I can share is that,
in that new normal, I might be able
to talk with you without this mask.
>> And it's going to be tough and
we all have to stay flexible,
which is lesson number one in business.
>> One thing I wish I knew at the start
of my GSB experience was to just breathe,
relax, and savor the moments that you will
undoubtedly share with your classmates.
>> Whether you're on campus or online
this quarter, we are here to support you.
>> Be grateful,
Stanford is a magical place and
it's very easy to forget to be grateful
when you're overwhelmed by everything.
>> Well, the GSB offers a great community
and a great communal experience.
Be sure to have honest and
difficult conversations with
yourself about where you are and
where you're headed.
>> I'll leave you with
the five values of GSB,
engage intellectually,
strive for something great,
respect others, act with integrity and
own your actions.
>> Welcome to the GSB
>> [MUSIC]